[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
say is destiny 2 is so much more than
the game we see in trailers while many
joined for the fantasy we found a home
amongst its people and in the end game
we stayed for the discos the dps the
grenades the bad bubbles burgers and
tannics behind every corner trombone
medleys laser tag tower names yeehaws
the dings the puns the clutcher kicks
sweeper bots stasis crystals cheese
spots raid call outs pump some ramen
sliding chicken petting gallery horns
sepik's prime shiny swords
thank you so much for joining us today
uh we are so excited to dive in and talk
about just the kind of journey of being
a massive destiny and bungie fan
and what that's like to go from massive
fan to actually working at the company
that we loved so much i want to learn
about your your journeys how did you get
started playing as a player not as
somebody who works here playing destiny
and kind of how is that relationship
with the game evolved through the years
you know what t you and i we've had many
conversations with session i want to
hear from you buddy
uh so i've been playing the game for a
little bit
just a little bit
yeah uh and so you know as proof of my
uh you know the d1 alpha veteran status
i have my raid belt here today uh
so uh this is this is my cringe moment
where i will be probably nice to see one
in person i've seen it on like screens
and like screenshots
like how'd you get it when did you get
it so uh that is the king's fall world's
first belt uh me and my five friends we
have to i say used to have but i think
we probably still have it uh world's
first of fun like whenever we were doing
world's first races it was supposed to
be about having fun and showing off the
new stuff uh and for me i always loved
writing just because like i'm a problem
solver by heart like that's also why i
love working here because that's what i
do is i just kind of solve problems that
are really complicated that's really
exhilarating and now
is very fun uh being able to watch
others suffer for 24 hours oh yeah
oh yeah because it's it is exhausting uh
so if you if you are if you are
listening to this and you are and you
are raiding or if you're planning on
raiding for a long time drink water
stretch bathroom break don't leave
bathroom please thank you don't let that
heart rate get too i'm very much with
sam on on this in terms of like the
loving the problem solving and loving to
get into that i really fell in love with
destiny when i started reading and that
was like my moment where i was like i
grew up playing puzzle games and mystery
games and like i love
those types of games and to find that in
destiny and to find
that same sort of like problem solving
but to do it with a team and to do it
with your friends i'm on the same page
yeah i'm totally on the same page like
the the number one story for me around
that is definitely deep stone
like i played all the way through deep
stone with my clan which was amazing
when you look back at the history of
destiny there's so many moments like
that and i'm kind of i'm kind of
interested on is there any characters or
story moments that really stick out to
you from our history i feel like that's
destiny at his best is like when you are
learning from it like at least for me i
feel like the journey of heiress from
like d1 and being like who are you what
are you doing here this is a weird
change yeah it's like super creepy right
yeah but i think like seeing where
she is now and then how she's like
really helped everyone else like a lot
of people i'm a huge zavala fan i'm a
titan it's just like in my blood
so like for me like seeing aerys like
help all of these different characters
seeing zavala come from where he is
which a lot of people again i i know
some folks that don't really like him
that much but to me he always just
seemed like a really
you know a father figure who's trying
his best for everyone
uh you know when kate died right i think
like you know people were like what like
why aren't you doing
and then we got to learn more about him
for me zavala is like number one that
like that his whole character arc and
then eris and like her character arc
you're all insufferable to them like
teaching everybody how to deal with
their demons yeah i think that's the
incredible speaking to now and like
through season 17 how aris she's like
one of the epitomes of grief in her
whole story and how she evolved to
something where she's like i had to
learn how to deal with grief on my own
and to see her evolve to a character
that is like helping people go through
their own grief it's bunji what the heck
like how do you do this
patient she was like the fact that like
when crow would stumble or zavala would
stumble she'd be like
take a step back patience healing
doesn't happen overnight and exactly i
think what we've seen in the last couple
of seasons of the incredible narrative
team and just diving deeper into all of
the characters i think that's one of my
favorite things that we've we've seen
from the kind of expansion from where we
started to where we're at now is just
that deeper dive and i know
kind of where we're going with things
and just like the more that we're going
to be able to dive into and and hear
characters backstories and understand
where they're coming from and what makes
them
i think to everyone's point it just
makes it more than
just a shooter game you have that
additional aspect of these incredible
stories that we all connect with in
different ways and it just makes it it's
the bungee magic it's the space magic
it's the thing that like then you do a
little emote jig at the end yeah exactly
and it all it makes sense it's called
glimmer gun yeah
yeah
but like how cool is it like that we're
here now and i'm i'm kind of interested
like
knowing your your long relationship with
this game before you even worked here
and then that we're sitting on this
couch getting to nerd out and talk about
the things that we love the most
how has that been
making that transition what was that
inspiration that drove you to be like
you know what
i'ma put my application in we'll see
what happens this is my first gaming
studio for sure yeah it's a
getting into bungie is interesting
because i always wanted to be in tech
that's really where i started for
destiny specifically i played it every
day but i never really thought of it as
a place to work um until black at bungie
uh and so i reached out to a bunch of
people on linkedin and was asking a
bunch of questions i was like look look
so it was really amazing to be able to
like get into
the industry and get into bungie destiny
for me was
uh that was back when i was streaming
for fun it was just a hobby but then it
became just a lot more to me because it
has all these things i love about games
i love rpgs i love you know like the the
game feel of a bunch of game right when
like you you shoot that gun for the
first time and it just feels good you
know space magic yeah face magic space
and i always play the wizard so i played
the warlock
um you know because that's all i want to
do i just want to cast base magic in
every game that i play so to me the
game's a lot like it's kind of just it
gave me a career uh it gave me like
guidance in life for finding a community
that i really love um and how i'm
absurdly uh thankful that i can be a
part of the team and hopefully make the
game better to hopefully have that kind
of impact on somebody else i knew that i
wanted to work in gaming i actually got
the opportunity not from the bungie
career website but from a twitter post
um from between
the twitter post and i immediately sent
the message and connected and i was like
i want to talk about these marketing
opportunities
and now i'm here
even now just the fact that i'm sitting
here i'm just like you shot your shot
dude that's what life's about literally
i shot my shoes i'm like this is what
they mean because you hear them throw
that phrase around and you're just like
but what does it actually mean to shoot
your shot and it's like no it's like
you're not going to respond on twitter
it's like i'm going to find you in other
places even if you're going to comment
even if you have that moment of fear
because sometimes to making a jump like
that's scary
if you're scared absolutely do it anyway
yeah yeah the leap into bungie was
really similar to will story this is my
first role in gaming so it was this like
huge
leap to i had been working in marketing
for for a long time but i really wanted
to
make the switch to something that i'm
really passionate about and something
that i love because i think that's what
makes work so magical is when you get to
work on something you really care about
and you really really love and you feel
passionate about so that for me was the
kind of thing that pushed me towards
shooting my shot and taking my shot a
couple years ago and and making the
switch over to bungie and it's it's been
incredible there's moments like this
where it feels very surreal where you're
like what is happening this is very very
just to have that like we all work at
bungie now like we get to contribute to
that thing that we all love so much and
that's
incredible
i'm sorry but that's a such a good point
because there's so many people that ask
us
like advice on how to get in and
i was rejected numerous times before
finally getting that spot
and you know i know it breaks my heart
because so many other people are in that
same position and then they stop and
they stop chasing that dream because
like this isn't my first gaming job i
i've been working in this industry for
almost 20 years and as a journalist and
it was really scary to make that jump i
just i felt like it was right i kept
applying for narrative and you know
granted i sent them
not appropriate fan fiction as writing
people so yeah
no hard feelings i get it uh and they
were like you know it was it was just
they were like hey we think you'd be a
good fit for community like let's put
you through that interview process and
we did that and it was scary at first
but the more i kept interviewing i was
like wait no this is
this was made for me like this is what i
was supposed to do and it was funny
because all of that trepidation that
first week left because i i felt like it
was family i'd like to think that bungie
gives space for that human condition
that human element it's a place where i
can feel like i can be myself it's a
place where i am
being taken care of and i'd like to
think that you know we're not perfect
and there's things we can improve upon
but we try to talk about those things
well thank you guys so much for joining
us today it was honestly so much fun
just diving into your stories a little
bit not just like as devs and working on
bunnyside but as players before that and
the journey into that
i'm really also excited for the upcoming
showcase so i'm gonna need you all to
meet me matt in the back we're gonna do
a blanket burrito and we're gonna hunker
down with some popcorn
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
hello old friend
this is everything i've ever wanted out
of the story
oh my god i love it
nasty son your life
that was hot
sir are you okay
oh you nasty
what the prank is that the witness man
that's crazy
which one you what is it the twitch one
what you're doing
okay
screw it up
what's going on
it is the day
welcome guardians
so awesome to be here with you again
last time we got up here
we got a chance to show you sabathune
the witchy queen on the majestic throne
world got it since then it's been a wild
year for destiny
you returned to the original loot cave
to reclaim the fabled galler horn then
you exercised an ancient stream will
begin
so you could put it inside a grenade
launcher
and now you've been spending the past
few weeks okay yes
leviathan from its twisted nightmares in
fact the last year has been the best
year we've ever had in the destiny
community i hope you can feel it as well
and seeing this kind of reaction from
our community
it's both humbling and inspiring because
our team here at bungie we're not just
developers you're talking to the david
check out soon we're
and that's what brought each one of us
here
brought us not only to bungie but also
brought all of us to this final showdown
between light and darkness
so without further ado
this
is the beginning
of the end oh oh let's get it
it's light bulb
the beginning of the end
spain
it
to its
is bathing
he's always bathing the royal bats for
the witness
yes
aka strand are we spiderman
who is spiderman
oh it's sony now so yeah and i said
that's the spot there's the influence
that's how we got it see we wouldn't got
that without sony all right thank you
instantly i had chills
it's all here it's all happening now
things are finally coming to a head
thematically we really have been honing
in on that kind of bombastic big set
piece approach it's gonna be over the
top action adrenaline pumping like the
whole time
this is really kicking off the
conclusion to the light and dark saga
where we finally face down this foe that
we've been anticipating facing for so
long it's pushing it to 11.
choice we've been hinting at this
malicious force in the darkness that's
been our enemy behind a lot of our
conflicts we revealed that enemy we put
a name in his face
a new and more powerful army than ever
before
they've got new powers they've got new
armor they've got tormentors to join
their ranks that are going to be bigger
and better no who is dogs callus is
taking that army that he's bringing with
him to be the harbinger
i like the cyberpunk feel
it looks good
for destiny everyone is coming to have a
last stand with kallus and the witness
to really avoid the next collapse
something that we've been trying to
avoid ever since destiny won
i don't know where this locale is that
was all right i was saying is it all
it's not on the market
we see in the trailer that we're headed
to neptune
neptune there's been this hidden city
called neomuna where an alternate
version of humanity has been blooming
since the collapse
neo-muna is the capital city of neptune
it's a giant metropolitan
completely unaware existed until now
what's interesting and exciting to me
about this place is that it's pristine
it's new it's not like a lot of the
places that we've explored previously in
destiny exploring that space is very
very cool there's so much new stuff to
discover in nyomuna and in neptune and
also i saw some new characters there i'm
really excited to get to know cloud
striders and their story cloud shriners
who the hell is this
cloud striders can be compared to
guardians they're both protectors of a
civilization that's potentially under
threat but guardians were chosen
it's their duties they look fine
humanity cloud striders have chosen to
protect their people this counts an
awesome opportunity for the guardians to
learn from the cloud striders and their
way of living and their philosophy of
life so we've got the newness of that
city the newness of the cloud striders
that we've never been aware of and then
of course you get a glimpse of this
green just get it
spidey i wonder what that is
it's about time darkness let's go over
here don't you end this season
unlike any of these other powers we've
ever had before
when you play through lightfall
you are discovering this power for the
first time no one in the universe
ever in the history of destiny has used
strand before this is the guardian
discovering darkness on their own kind
of thing with everything
well the other one was given to us alice
and his forces
and you know have fun this is us
that's it we're going to be doing this
during the city
all i'm doing the
while playing this game we just got a
glimpse of our new destination neo moon
our new foe kallus and the she
definitely looks like
the witness and
a very brief glimpse at strand but
that's just barely scratching the
surface of what this release has
right like what what we've just seen in
that trailer is just the tip of the
iceberg and we've got a whole lot more
exciting
last year we wanted to return to our
studio's roots in creating some of the
best shooter campaigns in the industry
that's been our legacy since hayla
talked to him and we tried to push that
front and center in the witch queen and
it's about more than just
best campaign
absolutely full of surprises
then we have the legendary campaign
option yes because great combat needs to
challenge you to test your thumb skill
your tactics and your build crafting and
we heard loud and clear that you want
more of that mm-hmm in fact two out of
every three players that completed the
witch queen campaign did it as legendary
you tested yourself against the witch
queen interlucent hive even grace beat
the game on legendary and then you let
us know it was one of the best sets of
experiences that we've ever made no just
stand alone
we want to push that even further we
want to give you the best bungee action
experience that we can create with the
brand new light fall campaign let's go
we get a little preview lightfall is
going to change the way that our players
move fight and explore
everywhere in destiny neptune is this
fantastic destination the capital city
of neomuna is a really fun place to
explore and it's this bright neon
metropolis there's a harbor office
buildings an arcade
this is a city that we've made and using
strand to traverse through it and
explore it it's going to be so exciting
spider-man is good
i'm gonna be able to everyone
you couldn't before look at that up
there i wonder if i can grapple to there
i'm gonna be a kid in a candy store
that's crazy they put in that level of
mobility mechanics it's collapsed it is
a city that has lived through the
collapse
neptune now has to deal with the cloak
being pulled back and then being
revealed to the world and are now
central of the conflict callus has taken
his capital ship and just like planted
it right down in part of the city and
it's cabal occupied territory it's a
city under siege you've got this
infiltrator vibe at times where you feel
like a tactical team going into a
skyscraper you're dealing with cabal
roadblocks and patrols all throughout
the city
the shadow legion they provide that like
characteristic cabal
brute strength they're all about like
volatility and power and they've been
enhanced now by pyramid technology they
have these suppression devices that can
take away some of your super or take
away some of your abilities and then
they fight alongside these terrifying
armadine it's called tormentors that's
why i want to know what's going on yeah
that's part of
it has been upgraded and so the
tormentors that they've brought in are
these impossibly huge
unstoppable behemoths they wield
sciences they can attack from a distance
they can bring you in close they can
drain your very life force from they are
basically embodiments of terrorism
give us fear like the high level of
loose energy
that's what destiny needs having fun
popping heads doing this thing and then
boom
there it is
we've got all the new stuff going into
the game strand tormentors shadow legion
a cool new environment these are all a
great setting for a new legendary
campaign and we're still making sure
that we go through and we tweak and tune
and we balance the encounters to have
that right challenging level of
difficulty for players the legendary
campaign was a huge hit coming out of
the witch queen it was the first time we
had done that sort of elected difficulty
where you could really test your skill
and test your power and so we're going
to bring that back for light fall of
course you're still going to have that
high reward tier and we still want to
make sure that you get that inside track
towards being rave
on
ready
putting in the details and making this
whole release come alive and continue to
surprise and delight players i am so
excited to get this out lightfall is
unlike anything players have seen before
in destiny and it's another step that
sends you hurdling to the conclusion of
the light and dark saga
conquer yourself
yeah look
serious
oh well okay
all right
something's gonna be so broken come on
yeah amazing i'm super excited pvp is
gonna be wild
and talk oh
unlike our light abilities which are all
about creation darkness is more about
consciousness
strand is psychic energy
it's the same powerful
matrix that connects everything together
remember connects all living beings and
all minds and you the guardian are sort
of gaining the knowledge and gaining the
power to peer into this alternate
psychic universe and begin to pull at
these threads and tug at these wires
that are connecting all these living
beings
when guardians learn how to use strand
it's almost like this third eye opens up
it's about peeling back the curtain of
reality taking those connections and
then weaving them like objects that's
fine yeah and it's pretty cool to see
them coming yo that's fine with the rope
and now that we can tap into it we can
use it for our benefit whether it's
through movement or
through damage
strength has
since you're seeing anywhere is just
there
you are able to grapple at anything
that's
it's about
right so we made the call to expand the
super cool new video across all three
classes
let's go
on the design side we wanted to come up
with how each of the classes interpreted
this additional psychic dimension like
in their own way right
so the world they're the telekinetic
master strand so they're going to be
able to telepathically reach into the
strand dimension the whole matter out
and weave it into this big barrage of
these strand missiles
he got stranded
and these missiles are actually going to
unravel sort of re-weave themselves into
a new form
with the titan you're able to she's cute
and
oh
we've learned a lot from our other sub
classes and we've taken those learnings
about combat about movement about build
crafting we put that all into strand and
i'm so excited to see where players take
it once it's out there in the wild
excited to say you guys nerfed it once
you put it in the water oh yeah
this is gonna be over here
and then we're gonna get nerf the next
round next season
so use it up enjoy it yeah use it at the
light for get get your rocks off they
will be nerfed after destiny is a game
when you play with your friends
we want to create communities that are
welcoming inclusive
and they'll let you bring your old
friends and make new ones
and since last year
over
we believe that there are still millions
more of your friends that would love it
with you and the things that you want to
see us improve in destiny are also
exactly what's going to make it easier
it should be easier to create custom
incredible builds
easier to find people to play with
easier what are they doing
right into that ultimate yee hein dead
man's tail shooting satan's rampart
crutching scent
because of what joe just said makes
sense to you we want to fix that too
because it's not about removing the
depth that makes destiny so great it's
instead about allowing everyone to dive
deeper with ease what are y'all doing
i'ma go to all the old jumping puzzles
were strained
the changes we're making to make destiny
easier i don't hear anything
about how you build your characters
changes oh multiple logos what there is
to do and what there is to accomplish
and in the year ahead we're actually
making it easier to form groups in
destiny so you can go and do some of the
greatest content that destiny has to
offer all the teams are working together
that you're going to just vote away in a
year
that's right i know i'm like
hearing from players like hey unless i
have a friend to play with i don't know
what to do yes and so we're trying to
give them is like hey here's a path to
follow it's a little late guardian ranks
guardian ranks basically like a
knowledge ladder we actually progressed
you through 11 ranks and it's really
like heavily focusing on like exposing
players to all the systems of destiny oh
yeah
dj don't we know someone that does this
very well other guardians
don't know anyone that is just a whole
new dimension of your journey through
destiny that we've never really explored
before when you show up in the tower and
you see that person who's at one of the
highest ranks you're going to know that
you're looking at a player who's
actually really demonstrated mastery of
many of the different activities
from
our perspective but from the perspective
of other players some of the higher
guardian ranks will actually be asking
for you to step up to actually rise to
the occasion and prove to other
you are a strong player and you should
be psf
back where you are a lot of people have
groups that they already play with but
this will really provide people the
opportunity to be recognized for
helping other people learn the game but
also provide more people to play with
in-game sharpeners
investing in building uh looking for
group systems
you'll be able to look for other players
you'll be able to find groups that are
looking for players
going to reward shepherds for actually
doing yeah they have to because we might
get in there because i i hope it ain't a
guided game situation everybody tried
that d2
but this is like a serious attempt
i want to take them for that first grade
because well friends it's a great
experience for them yeah but you better
friend game my my my paycheck and my
exotics together
i ain't doing that for free better when
they've never met before well you
kidding the guardians i needed check
i think that it's going to really make
destiny players feel like they're on one
team oh wow so commendations is a
feature that you'll experience towards
the end of an activity so you end the
activity now and you get to see the
screen that has all the people you play
and i want to see the dps
and choose what experience you have full
results right
four results up there
yep there's no better way to actually
show how good a person is as a team okay
this this is what needed to be done
players say this person
oh you could call me oh he's really dj's
toxic this one's toxic
players show appreciation for each other
also dj don't like new players people
are gonna be able to say like hey this
is
give you an opportunity to like really
connect with other people and do things
together and get to know each other this
is a good thing that's a good feature
this is going to help you make it like
more people can get that way i could be
as toxic as i want and i get rewarded
ever before
oh my god both the loadout screen and
the mod manager
they try to put them out of business
build construction destiny
is amazing and so we're going to take
what we did for the fashion game and
we're bringing it to the build chrysler
there's going to be one screen where you
can go to and do your entire loadout for
your characters it's going to be amazing
so you'll be able to save the build that
you've put together as a loadout and
then switch between those things as
you're going from activity taxes let's
go yeah but yo this is about gm build
it's the red yeah
yeah i'm i love builds and mods
we're giving places oh that's right new
aspirations
nobody needs anti-barriers it's also
going to be about that guardian rank
it's going to be about like
but it does help it does help dj
so today we are also launching a brand
new season of destination now and as
we've evolved our seasons over the years
and i think we've been able to deliver
some amazing
talking with his dead game in this
community is your game still the era of
time
instead
there are exciting story and events
happening in destiny almost every week
year round and we're not saying i love
that destiny gives slow balls a chance
to get see what god look like for
narrative experiences in any livestream
we want to keep pushing to create
unexpected
that'll make every season of destiny
unique and we want to keep listening and
learning from you the destiny community
so that we can create the strongest
seasons of any live service
because the witness
is coming
and if we want to survive
we need a crew
way better defensive not what the player
counseling certainly maybe
enemies
we may even need to find the captain
well the player count down adventure in
the season of plunder plunder
yeah
those leaks are right i was reading it
erebus
they're all coming back pirates
oh 3.0 baby let's get it
is that starting today
yeah that's today
we're doing some chips i love it
that's definitely what it is this is 3.0
no i said why this is game bit 2.0 the
ship stuff oh yeah for sure bring your
treasure to see your stars await
wait we using the ships
are we using the ships sorry getting a
little swept up in all this adventuring
ah
this looks fire
i am not going for it
i got the sweater six though so we're
gonna get another december because
february august this is december okay
okay
let's get it what are you most excited
about for season of plunder
oh stop saying yeah barely on life
support you don't get out of here
this season we said what if we just go
to the stars and dig up buried treasure
mysteries and secrets we're
swashbuckling on
these spaceships the live service king
is back though some of our favorite
characters we're gonna have an adventure
this season
who would do that
seasonal plunder kicks off with aramis
being freed from her icy prison she's
collected old fallen crews of pirates
and rogue cabal together in order to
function they did that with them you
gotta board the ships
so guardians are tasked with stopping
aramis from collecting these things
in order to do that you have to create
your own crew of shady dealers and back
room brokers drifter myth racks idaho
what you're going to be doing is
performing a pirate crew of your own
you're going to fill it with different
crew members that you can recruit over
the course of the season i hope that
you're playing
the keys to your personal catch then
you're just going to set out into the
stars and do cool pirate stuff
so excited
this is hilarious to me this season we
have multiple brand new activities
coming that will really give you a sense
of being on a pirate adventure one of
the mainstays of this season is a new
six player offensive called catch crash
and i saw the concept for the catch with
the big you're in charge of sales
just like seeing catch crash through the
different iterations like fighting on
the deck of the ship you get to become
your own yeah where did they get that
idea
see your friends see your friend baby
the second big activity we have coming
this season is called expedition
you're gonna be guiding a massive drill
that's looking for this buried hidden
pirate treasure and you're gonna have to
be fending off of all these pirate crews
trying to protect their points
oh now you capping for warframe which
game isn't you trying to compete
these are their caves where they're
hoarding all of their amazing treasures
and their mysterious relics these relics
are mysterious objects of dark power and
they're all over the system we don't
know exactly what it is they do yet but
she's
trying to collect them it's nothing good
perfectly because you've got all the
simple uh
captains it actually looks right with
that release yeah almost like we planned
it arc is a damage type that's about
proximity right it's about going fast up
into your enemy's faces and like shorter
shorts
the damage type for people that want to
hold w you don't want to retreat
unbridled aggression to the max
hunter is really about close range
action being fluid and dynamic and and
agile evasive so we're going to give our
country a new super uh we call it
gathering
where you summon your staff like twirl
above your head and then launch it out
and then it will embed into the ground
or into like bosses or mini bosses or
champions and jolt them like a big
lightning strike will strike the staff
and overcharge it and while that staff
is overcharged it'll start tesla coiling
little lightning bolts out of nearby
enemies
warlock is kind of this elemental
conduit you are a class that will turn
yourself into lightning and create
things out of lightning previously you
know we had this exotic armor piece
called getaway artists where you consume
your grenade it'll make a
anytime you are amplified any ark soul
you have from any source
will become the super convergence
that will fire off just rapid fire bolts
so basically getaway artist
for free titan's about being this
unstoppable freight train it's about
this constant movement so we gave
titan's a new movement option
he's getting all that
is like rush down or getaway it's a
movement tool to the max
there's going to be a ability called
thunderbolt which is like an amazing
thing where he like charges down like
this right here this is too dominant
right he's never tried this seems bad
for a lot of things yeah
this is too dominant for titans i'll
like this right here
they got two let's make it let's make it
easier for them to believe in pvp of
full charges
it is oh yeah it's a little skillful
like it really isn't that complicated
it's move fast
hit hard
and stay alive
share the titan doing the most
what i'm most excited about in the
season of plunder is that this is really
a season that has a sense of adventure
you're you're expecting a music system
of the original music yes you're seeing
the world evolve in a way we haven't
done before
i love that with the activities in the
season like we just leaned really hard
into the pirate fans that's the grass of
arabis music
it's what they did they
people loved it yeah it was good it was
good don't you after the pirate leaders
in their caves the interesting thing
about destiny is we're not just a
fantasy game or a sci-fi game we're kind
of a blend of boom everything take
inspiration when we say pirates it's old
world pirates that you oh plunder bus oh
they can definitely start
lock pistol we have an exotic fusion
rifle that plays different than fusion
rifles
before it's
let's also make it so that new players
coming in can actually jump in and get
started the gift of the thunder gods
it's a thunderlord exotic weapon so john
the captain join your friends
set sail become the captain and build
your crew today
today
get your crew got me we we knew that was
happening
all kids let's go
let's go
let's get it oh it's a wrap it's a wrap
it's a wrap higgs ball is back
guess who's happy
oh no oh look at that wall i love them
oh cheaters
[Music]
let's get to the beat of the peter the
phallic whoa oh you use faces yes
i forgot no no take that away no no we
have to leave it that's for me
the king is
competition
to destiny yeah actually king's fall was
the first thing i got to work on it but
and i'm thrilled that a whole lot of
achievement guardians will get to
experience this refreshed and reloaded
showdown what they're taking
so
we've shown you life just kidding we've
shown you the new damage type strength
yeah we've shown you some of the deeper
changes to the game that we're going to
be making throughout the next year
we have one more thing that we are
excited to announce today destiny is
coming to the epic games oh
i think it's
budgie getting mad bags hey bad gamers
destiny and we are just huge
what they've been doing
i
and they had a bunch of the same stories
for us
they shared stories about playing the
vault of glass and how much they enjoy
the social experiences and destiny bill
over there doing the lord's work at epic
games fortnite chapter one season five
when my whole family was laser focused
taking turns in the island to unlock
gold in addition to launching all of
store for destiny
update for the next week if you download
all these new guardians with a
celebration
one that stretches a little further
than the last city
yes
oh my god what are we doing now oh it's
fourth night let's get oh [ __ ] oh dj dj
you good are you good though
you're so excited right now oh you
didn't get it
it's over we are literally the zeitgeist
of the culture we are the culture
destiny is the closure
hey a fortnight eight eight hey slo-mo
how does it feel the threes the three on
top
this is the culture we're forced to all
right we're
everything that's popping you cannot
escape destiny that's how it is benzene
you cannot escape this is how does it
feel
hey hey slo-mo slo-mo how does it feel
that division ain't in this
since we started charting our own life
we've been building this story
across five years of expansions since
the first pyramid ship emerged from
chassis and we first spoke to the dark
knight still doing what the goat doing
preparing our technology and our game to
last for many years
sir they gave us a bag
anywhere
and neither are your expansions
we want this story since we first
communed with the darkness on the moon
to be fully played oh start today
oh let's go maddie i get mr maddie
please let's go we want the destiny
universe to grow up
but enough about the distant future
let's talk about today
the best day all year to jump at a
destination
i just
all expansions are free to play for this
entire week only for the week
they said just put a week
right here charges next week he said
thunderous live
and the helm's got a set of stuff
get your knees in there looking to catch
up on the fun that's right destiny is
live on the epic game
you can download everything and you can
get the 30th anniversary pack as your
welcome gift and if you liked what you
saw about the future oh right now
pre-orders and flight fall are live on
all platforms
and anyone who purchases the oh i need
that it's the exotic auto rifle quick
silver storm silverstone today
today is a perfect day
oh this is my thing this is the greatest
dream they had in a long time
and they've had great streams my
publications
actually to be honest with you they're
big
they're big streams they rarely drop the
ball they really drop the balls yeah
3.0 pirate ships see these episodes what
are they not doing epic store it's crazy
it's crazy right there
crazy see see slo-mo this is why we have
to go back to this piece of [ __ ] game
because they always be delivery
you know it's crazy
they're literally going from dragon ball
z to destiny on fortnight like it's just
there's not a more influential game in
existence there just isn't like
it's crazy bro
i don't it's crazy how much bags that's
they got from every platform they're so
smart
they're probably going to make more
money off their skins on destiny than
they've made all i mean on fortnite than
they've made on destiny
wow fantastic stream oh fantastic
yeah there you have it there you have it
hey wilhelm's here well he's been here
this whole time he's been this whole
time he's been quiet he didn't say a
damn word to me he's there we're
screaming scream not screaming
he's like i've been muted this whole
thing
screen what up
you might get i wonder what you're
feeling
was he yeah he probably stepped away so
people were asking earlier if we're
going to react to the
the
jeff keeley thing apparently they're
supposed to announce stuff there when it
keeps dropping
later on today
it depends what time today is my
schedule's pretty much it's like 6 p.m
6 p.m there's a possibility yeah
what time is that start chat put it in
uh
[Music]
oh he's reconnecting i see he's trying
to connect his audio let's see what's
going on down here scream yeah he's
jumping in with a second
while we wait for scream dj
how are we feeling sir uh is the worst
one so far i'm not excited about
anything
it's all it's all amazing they they
killed it um
i'm hyped for this season and you know
last season wasn't a thing for me so
uh this is this is looking good and the
expansion's in february so and yeah yeah
so that means we're going to get another
season after that
i think this season is going yeah that's
a good question because the season ends
seasonal plunder ends in december right
right and then
from december to february is there a new
season that's a good question i bet you
there's something similar to the um
the 30th anniversary thing so which
would be cool because if they put
something out like that i'm happy
you guys hear me now we get your screen
whatever where are you what's going
that's the energy what's the temperature
i think it's going to be a good season
it's going to be a long season but it's
going to be a good one
and uh
yeah um
why is there a new season
yeah
there's a lot in there i mean what
exciting everything looks really cool
the new the subclass that subclass is
going to be
so broken yeah yeah like they do yo bro
you could
just hand me oh you know oob glitches
just
hand them to me
oh my lord it's gonna be so easy i'm
subscribing right now even even like
even novices will be able to uh you know
get out of bounds with that um
oh no and i think uh yeah i mean i think
it's just gonna be really really cool i
think everybody i mean king's fall is
like i think
probably the biggest thing
yeah but i know but everybody knew that
so
it's crazy man
what'd you feel about season on a
plunder
like i said i think it's gonna be a good
season i i don't know how like any of
these like i feel like the new
was it the catch
activity is pretty much going to be um
uh dares of eternity okay
essentially but like there's a
fraternity in the um
uh
grasp of avarice dungeon
it's gonna be like yeah like a six-man
grasp of everest dungeon and then like
uh
yeah i'm trying to think with the other
thing that stood out to me was um i mean
it's cool that they're doing all the
free to play stuff and um
that they're doing all the crossover
definitely seems like there's uh
some budget
that came their way recently yes yeah so
i told you guys
that soda bag drops
he said y'all need that spider-man
influence from straight let's go that's
going to be really cool i want to see
how big that sandbox is going to be
you know like if it's if it's like a
full-on um if it's like something the
scale of what was in like scores of the
past like in the beginning
you know uh
like if it's like free to roam in that
way that'd be cool i think like
maybe something like double that size
would be really really cool and you're
just able to do stuff within it versus
just like going through it like the
thing about destiny that always kind of
like
i i always get a little irked when they
because they have such potential for
some of these spaces where
it would be worth it to be able to have
to go around and not just through you
know what i mean so i hope that it's
more of just like a big
playable area yeah that would be that
would be awesome and i think i think
like that's what it seems like certainly
so you know
not a favor
attic man you seemed excited
yeah i i like uh you know they're
finally showing us new
new ads and stuff and we got a couple
new creatures i'm still a little
disappointed we ain't seen like a new
faction like i kind of expected like
when the darkness showed up like a whole
new darkness faction and not just like
one or two ads
that just creep with the with the cabal
it's going to be interesting to actually
conclude the callous
thing because we ain't never even seen
this dude in like real life
uh so it i i think i i was definitely
hyped but it was more of like the social
aspects that they're putting in the game
not like story-wise like i feel like i
need to see a little bit more story-wise
no i feel yeah i mean i'll jump in
completely blown away i came in
not that i came in with low expectations
but it's like it's always like how can
they
gain excitement again and they always
knock it out the park with the expansion
stuff but yeah this was a lot i think um
the
the quality of life stuff really
impressed me like the
the loadouts the
in-game lfg
stuff that people have been crying for
for years that that integrated in the
game in a cool way is
really cool that's going to help the
user base even more
they they really did it like then they
go on uh no more sunsetting which is
which is huge because that means
the argument for sunset was that the
game was getting too big
so now them doing that that to me seems
that there's a long term play and i'm
curious if by lightfall
we don't get the announcement that they
sunsetting them old consoles
cause the game the reason why they said
sunset came out in the first place was
because the game was getting too big and
they still had that past generation so
i'm curious if that whole
you know what i'm saying like we finally
cuz right now you can still play it on
ps4
yeah it'll be a real console except for
the playstations i don't right i don't
think uh they're doing that i think that
the most thing you're gonna see
because to me i feel like if they were
doing that it would have been announced
there i feel like they've just they've
found a way in the back end of stuff to
uh to help with the transition a little
bit more i don't know man i i disagree i
think that
the whole reason why they said i
remember that announcement when sun said
it came like it was yesterday it was
like the constraints of the game are too
big they were like we just cannot keep
adding content and this is the way and
people were mad at them and they were
like we're sorry that's what it is and
then we'll we'll bring some things back
here and there and reimagine it you talk
about permanently not getting rid of the
content anymore
and this was a lot of issues that like i
said maddie you want to get it people
want to get in destiny like i want to
play from start to finish
so if you're going to play from start to
finish and have all that stuff
i mean hey i hope if you write and they
figured out a way on the back end
to technically
solve that kudos today the greatest
developers
like kudos to them that would be crazy
but we'll see we'll see i thought that
was called
um
yeah what
everything about life falls fire to me
everything about like like i love
once you throw like a cyberpunk essence
kind of vibe
i'm in it look like a populated city we
got a new race that these clouds try to
do that look cool i am with judo attic i
thought we would get more
newer people besides obviously it's
callous his people and then you got this
hard bridge that thing that looked
unstoppable but i did agree i thought
we're going to get more of that race
in that so i'm with you there and maybe
the vibe i'm getting now
we're gonna get that in final shape
you know what i'm saying
they stolen
the the witness race uh
they're giving us like a little more
taste so here it is and callus is cruel
but we're getting the full darkness race
the way it is but um no i thought i
thought it was cool and surprisingly
this season stuff look look hot too the
um
i love to see if these d i go for i
thought that's a great call
to catch that you know say the fall in
mythrax is okay yeah i mean not mr
what's her name aaron miss is a little
i'm with you guys it's a little late
like yeah we knew she was gonna come
back like all right we're gonna see you
okay fine but the activities look fun so
yeah the activities look fun i think me
is just like i like how they're finally
starting to open up destiny to new
characters in general but it's just like
come on man like we should be get like
it seems like there's a new like faction
that's gonna be an ally but she's like i
wanted that to be an enemy like
you wanted to fight them doing this
no it's not even for them it's just
we're just fighting with the ball again
they fight the cabal
with his big bro one big bro
look crazy though yeah but it's just
like
to me
we've been fighting the same factions
for like 10 years it feels oh no of
course of course it's like now we're
just going to put a big block on their
back that's not a big bro come on
big brother he knew you ain't see big
bro one of those things the harbingers
yeah big bro with the harbinger that's a
whole new
thing yeah that's a whole new thing like
serious like
pyramid head vibes from that guy i hope
it's something like that but you know
what be cool is like if those things are
just like randomly scattered out there
you have to go around and like avoid
them and like they see you it's like
certain yeah kind of like the gorgons or
something but i have a feeling it's
gonna be one of those things or they're
just going to be like an ad that pops up
on the map like they're just i don't
think it's going to be like one of those
things where you have to avoid them like
they're just it seems like they have a
little bit of darkness energy with them
and they can kill you pretty easily yeah
i'm getting gonna
i would love a quest where there's like
something like that that roams around
and you
have to go and like kill a certain
number of them and it's tied to part of
an exotic like quest line like that
would be so cool
to me
like something you have to it's really
kind of tough like that like try maybe
like you could maybe kill one of those
on your own if you're lucky but
maybe once you're with three people you
know what i'm hoping for is they keep
harping about how the campaign was the
best campaign ever
everyone loved it we all agree and hot
one thing that made people around made
that campaign fight besides the story
was great everything was great was hive
guardians we truly had a threat and then
we had to be uncomfortable go out there
get the ghosts otherwise they keep
coming back and then they could kind of
one hit kill you so i think they're
leaning on that would i'm gonna keep
calling him big bro in the big darkness
bro you know i said i don't know
i think they trying to change our place
because they kind of was like yo when
that thing is on the map
it is tremendous fear like this is
almost unstoppable they said like an
unstoppable force i think was the
terminology that they use so
i like that because to me
like i'd say like we keep fighting to
say enemies we're going we're going to
dust off the cabal but when you got that
enemy like a hive guard or unstoppable
thing that
adds a whole dimension of fear into the
playing field and i want to see how that
plays i mean it's
it's definitely going to be something
new to face i'm not really taking the
terminology too much to heart i feel
like it's like it's just a lot of amping
up on marketing i'm pretty sure you know
this dude will be this dude gonna take a
couple more bullets than the other ads
nah they're not doing that
they're not doing this right now they
are not doing that there could be a
couple but not the way they say you're
being way too negative on that
in a game where we're this powerful it's
going to take a couple more shots no
that's not the case
we could make a bet on that i'll make
him bet with you i don't think that he's
going to get like killed by like
literally two or three more shots like
even if you have to
shoot a couple more gallo horn shots
into them like i want to do faction i i
didn't want to just see one act what i
get that i'm just saying based on what
you want does it negate what that new
character is that's what i'm trying to
say but i understand your overall want
you're disappointed because you want
that and there's nothing wrong with that
you want more type of stuff like that as
opposed to just one little enemy i get
where you're going
all i'm saying is i bet anybody that it
ain't gonna be he just a little bit
tougher you just shoot a couple more
bullets and you down him that that's not
gonna be that character i could
guarantee you that
let's go flame one in real quick hold on
oh
sorry if we're gonna send you that oh
damn i'm about to head out
all right cool i just want to get his
comments real quick because he did
ask slow-mo that's just to write about
it
he's a number
his gaze don't have no stream
i i guess the reason that
i'm like it's not that i'm not feeling
the harbinger
it's just i wanted
more like
foot soldiers like it it's just like it
feels like they've always just
recycled the same four people it was
just like i wanted more foot soldiers
not like captains
no i get that scoring and but cause like
at the end of the day 88 of the stuff
we're gonna fight is gonna be cabal oh
yeah absolutely absolutely no i i get
that to me all that shows is
final shape that's what we kicked
off
and i think cause like the reason that i
was just disappointed is because like
this is supposed to be like
disappointing this is supposed to be
what's happening right when when the
darkness invades invades it it's just
like they're invading with with cabal
like you don't know what you don't know
what a raid will be like though like
they didn't say i mean that's that's
cool
but i oh
i just it is what it is man i mean it it
typical
i love my brother
the typical fan this is this is what he
do
i mean like to to to me
the darkness invades fully
with all this [ __ ] they didn't say that
you didn't listen to the story they did
not say that the whole purpose of
lightfall is that there's this planet of
neptune of this whole culture and race
that was hiding and that callous and
numb as the new disciples coming over
there to take them over and now we're
trying to protect them in a new ally to
your point the story where you're
talking about
i agree i thought that was what light
four was going to be so we are we
aligned there
what they're saying is i mean this is
this is a prequel to what's going to
happen in final shape where the full
invasion happened they're basically
stalling one expansion for the full fig
is what i got out of it but i understand
your point all right trust me i'm not
trying to minimize what you said
it is what it is i play it i mean i'm
not gonna never play it
you shot the best animal he said um
you know we said what do you mean
he said a state of the game
what is it a stream is it is it a live
is it new content what is he talking
about he said had a stayed in the game
what's going on with don't even talk to
him bro
do you got your skins in fortnite yet is
the division in the epics what's going
on dude do they got the crossovers yet
what's going on let me stop here man i
like i gotta kick him right kick him a
little bit when he down
i wanna know when we get dragon ball z
skins in destiny
yeah the epic story and then destiny is
just a dragon ball z multiplayer and uh
you know changing the game huh i mean we
already have the kamehameha wave then we
need to put that [ __ ] in the game
flame i sent you the drum i'm trying to
get you your balls before we head out
let me know
but um yeah man
i'm excited it's it's a show
you talk about what that dude was that
the the dusty
everyone doing the corner talking
reading off a piece of paper and we
let me stop division stop it
i love you though warframe is doing
anything you know slot the one there we
go there's lord ward frame i want to get
your ball before we go
lord warframe mr flame can you hear us
speaking of lord we're speaking of lord
warframe that real jack stuff with
season of the wonder let's go let's go
right i'm not gonna lie that actually
looks really cool for the season but
overall for like the light fall stream i
actually love like the i was expecting
that tone with it yes
what i like like i think one of the
people i was watching it with like they
still like is like like an old cyber
like a cyberpunk
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm looking at the locks i'm like
everybody else joint look how did it all
okay
but picture this right grapple hook all
the way up to the sky and launch down
eight missiles that track enemies that
track yes
for the floof gang that struggle with
jumps uh the fact that i could throw the
spider-man strand in in literally outer
space is that attached enough
muzzle problems we're good except yes
we're good i get my traversal oh let's
go
slow-mo said they checked he's just
someone said you know he said they jack
warframe tell us tell us what we're
thinking about so i want to know break
it down bring it down real quick so one
was the rail jack obviously yeah what's
really breaking down no i'm i'm
uneducated so the rail jack is really
like you go into space like they said in
the stream like you're able to go to
like different planets fight you know
like um enemies go into their ships take
their stuff anything like that it's
gonna be kind of like that and i
actually i'm not gonna lie i love that
they're bringing that into destiny
actually i think that's an awesome
gameplay guardian rank system though is
kind of like mastering as well for
warframe it's cool
i mean
to be fair it's a good system
it's a way to tell the difference
between
newbies and veterans so whatever secrets
i got that y'all doing over there that
we could we could implement
you'll see them on lognet soon i guess
let's see they bring back king's fall
i'm happy about that i just hope they
don't bring any new kind of mechanics
into it like they did with uh
now it was a baltic glass i think
they're gonna have champions and he's
gonna make way because
you know how
you know how fortnite can make a [ __ ]
ton of money yeah they put a cade skin
in there oh they put a case yeah they're
gonna take off
please i would go in there and just buy
it i wouldn't even play the game it's
just like master chief i would buy it
but speaking of which like they're
bringing all the skins and the fall guys
and everything like that i'm getting
their day one oh yeah
so overall
you you see you're excited you know i
mean as a person obviously you you
usually come for destiny for the
expansion that's your thing right you
wait for the expansions i might be
coming for the season actually because i
actually love what they're doing for it
it looks really really good i'm usually
going into space and taking you know
fallen stuff i just i love that at this
point i'm just in destiny for the lord
and raids like that's nothing that's
where you at that's where you're at
that's fine you know i'm saying i just
thought that um it was interesting the
themes that they chose were interested
interesting
decent choices it's gonna be fun man
gonna be a fun year we'll see how it
works out shout out to um epic shout out
to all the bags they got oh yeah oh my
god i love how they went on this whole
like tirade about like oh well you know
with epic games they're such innovative
things yeah it's like you've got money
to go into the studio
i love when they announce a new partner
they work with like you know we really
believe in stadium what they're doing
over there
like like a 10 page like thing on the
teleprompter thing yo let me tell you
though no one has mastered
getting paid for their game
by multiple suitors
then bun they are the goats we're
getting a bag there's no i've never seen
a game like this where they continue to
get bags this is crazy to me now the
only thing they got to do right now this
is where i agree with slo-mo he said
this earlier um
i was hoping
that we'd get the steam deck integration
announcement i don't think they're gonna
because i've seen them talk about that
on the stream once yeah they said that
it's it's technical issues and they
don't know that they can ever fix it
because of linux yeah i wonder if it's
not even just that apparently like when
they were doing pre stuff with it people
was using it to hack into their game
yeah and they not there especially where
they came from with the cheating and all
the
the the pre um anti-cheat era i i think
the the biggest thing that i am looking
forward to when it comes to life fall is
just like
getting more information on uh on on cow
so oh oh you mean on your own
you see him bathing in the ditch man he
looks he looks good in there he looks
good in there he bathed in lake
minnetonka it's good i can't wait to
have the raid fighting him because
hopefully that's
oh god
fighting a bathed floppy callus
listen you to get in the royal pools
in that one episode oh my god
look we're getting messy i do get a rap
but ah good stream good stream any final
thoughts anybody scream dj dj
just just just ready for it to happen
february's not that far away i thought
it was gonna be much further than that i
thought it would be march yeah i thought
it would be like an eight out of ten it
was a good thing for that complaint and
then you give it
it's just look like for years
for years
for years i have complained pretty
consistently over
factions uh-huh but you you was ripping
the stream like it was no i i still
liked what i saw
i still liked what i saw it's just i
wasn't feeling a new enemy faction
that's awesome
i didn't like the faction see this is
why i can't be saying this though
because i can't say anything let's get
some smart you're supposed to say
everything is fire and agree
that's right now we in cahoots right
you're supposed to be with me against
slo-mo so we can attack him so we don't
we don't want to give him any ammunition
so now it's a 10. i got it so 10 out of
10 perfect stream
god daddy mommy i get i guess i guess my
mind says
i said the callous hot tub rate i'm like
i get i guess
yeah i guess man i guess my mindset too
is at least it's not the hive again so
at least
he said that god is not dead
when i was with you i rolled my eyes a
little bit i was like
this again
i'm a little bit more understanding when
it comes to the seasons because you know
that's not like expensive content um you
know at least they gave us a new city i
am a little bit
i hope that these
the strain is built for more than just i
i
part of me hopes they didn't just make a
subclass
to
navigate through the city
and not really think about this subclass
after the city
the key is going to be think about all
the old content bringing strand into it
that's like going back to the word
context that's great that's going to be
interesting the thing that i like though
because at first i was scared too that
it was just a mobility kind of class but
then when i saw like the binding and
keeping people animated and stuck and
doing all this stuff i was like okay
there's other things to it clearly but
yeah i see what you say like i want to
see
the implementation or certain things
because
screen so you know we got the resident
breakers
um
i think there's a lot of potential for
exploring
they're about to put straight up
buildings around everything there ain't
no more
i mean to be honest with you you could
definitely probably get to a couple more
places than you couldn't go to but i
mean
it was pretty easy to try to to move
around with the warlock like they had a
lot of move uh mobility you know
features that they could do so i don't
think you could do a whole lot more with
this class you couldn't already do with
the warlock in terms of like getting
places you ain't supposed to go
i just yeah it makes my jumps you're on
other classes that's i think it'll be
easier on
all classes like the warlock is always
yeah the go-to i'm thinking of our
disciple and all those stupid things
when you gotta jump those gaps before
you fight rope
now you just strand over but you know
there's going to be a speed right that's
going to be like the thing you're going
to need to do there's going to be
something where you're going to need to
do that and it's going to be a difficult
like jumping i forgot about that you
know how bad the destiny drug be cat
daddy deleted his character he's back
and now and now he's like i bet you the
back of his mind he ain't coming out
openly and saying this he's like damn i
deleted my guardian it's like
the only destiny is the only game we
keep you come back
he had to delete his guardians to
encourage him not to come back
he was stopping the drugs see i will say
your people can say one thing i ain't
never did that
that's true that
what you call it raid light fall raid is
gonna have some section where it's gonna
be traversing traversal and going
through because they they're promoting
that here in that city you know
since they're making it
see here's the thing like
the fact that they're giving to every
class the some of the bosses might be on
platform fightings like where you need
to transition like yeah imagine like
something going around a room and you
have to constantly go to another
platform for it yeah so i mean it opens
up to like stuff you can do with every
class i was mainly talking about like
glitching into aries yeah i know what
you're talking about no i i'm looking
i'm thinking like dj remember on
prophecy dungeon boss fight
and remember how you had to chase him on
those platforms right
think about how creative you could be
and you could do interdimensional stuff
where you're chasing you're moving
around and fights and stuff like that
which stretch strand is encouraging the
movement so i think they're opening
themselves up to some cool thing i think
that ray is going to be really cool
whatever whatever the the environment is
i think it's going to be really cool
it's going to have a huge budget because
they got that
solely checked and cleared especially
i know that we joke around about it but
i i think you're going to see a lot more
from sony after this
me let's be real here thank you thank
you sony those though those checks just
cleared recently they go back and change
it something else tell you where they
caught them they got my meds out there i
i do think that
i i personally feel like if they didn't
they weren't bought another company like
sony
after
the next expansion not this one but the
one after that i think there is a good
chance that destiny might have died
after that
like because if matter would have took
off i think they might have focused on
that but now that since they have a
little bit you know something back in
them then i think they can focus on both
games but i don't think i agree i don't
know bungie could have focused on two
successful games i just don't know
especially with matter because mata was
what is it the vibe was like a pv like a
overwatch
shooter hero shooter
you need to dedicate resources i don't
know how they were going to do that in
that current state so it just comes down
to it it's just like i'm glad that you
know so i will i
i would i prefer to go into where it
went to
uh because i do think sony's gonna give
them options that i don't know if
microsoft would have
and i and i and i personally feel like
you know
as much as i'm
you know a little bit half and half of
destiny i still love the game i love the
lord
uh so i don't want it to end like i know
that sounds crazy i don't want the game
to happen i think you're in i honestly i
think you're not the country i think
you're in the expansion zone i think you
get the most excited with expansion but
i don't know if the seasonal mode has
been good for you protect based on your
unless there's a raid if there's a raid
in the season then it's like okay i'll
go check that out but i think you're
cool to just pop in do your little
expansions where they do the major
changes and then hop out
that's that's all they really care about
because i still buy the damn season
passes and buy the damn expansions
i'm probably good
see it it depends on how that
that player
event for the season is yeah like some
of them i like some of them i don't and
normally because they have you do a lot
of things in there in those events if i
like it i stick around more in that
season but if i don't i drop it after
like two days it's like
no doubt no doubt
hey look it was another good one shout
out to bungie that did they thing um let
me get ready anybody say they little
outros where they can find you all that
good
so i was screaming
real quick um
dj you busy at two
no what are we doing i guess me and you
uh me you and i'll hit up king see if
he's awake we'll we'll stream this this
gamescom thing because people have been
messaging me asking are we doing it
uh you know if i get a couple people i
i'll stream it i'll take like 30 minutes
to get something to eat and then i'll
come back and stream it
heard that
cool
what you got going on sir
you can just
search well i'm screaming uh
it's a good subscription um and uh i
will say
that the download is available it's 9.98
gigs
oh
thank you thank you for that thank you
for that they're refreshing the whole
game again
no doubt lords of gaming.oh
lord
frame not flame warfare okay
people find you what you got going on
sir
well i'm justin robco assistant editor
at wordsworthgaming.net i mostly write
all the warframe and now so frame
related stuff
and i am at flamelognet on twitter.com
no because i still need to be on there
for business purposes
behaving
the destiny bestie the homie the late
night
getting it in every raid dps arguing
doesn't sound like me at all
deep stone [ __ ] shaming i get to work
the first thing i hear when i join on is
hearing dj say i don't believe that
[Laughter]
bob bro
this is the dj orals we're gonna find
people find you uh people can find me in
the bungee store uh
uh if you want some uh some good great
help uh follow me on uh twitter or at
twitter and on twitch uh my my uh tag is
back for dead one
uh totally good time
crypt uh help um he's very solid but
always read but always reach out uh you
know dj worse everywhere um i'll give
you some hope and play some games yeah
but don't hit up dj ores because he's
horrible at that oh my god i agree
here you already know budgie with
another one a lot of fun a lot of
excitement definitely better expectation
for me but i'm curious to see what the
masses think once i see these social
media streets that's all i got attic
thank you for holding it down for me bro
all right and you can catch me at uh
lord attitude on twitter uh we will be
going live here in about another
40 minutes probably a little bit sooner
than that i gotta go get something
uh but we will be doing it people saying
it's 2 p.m damn it i wish it was three
all right but